Hey guys, I got some wonderful news to share with you. Congrats. Who's the dad? Nobody's the dad or the mom. We're giving birth to a new episode today. What? Yeah. Oh my God.
嘿，各位，我有一些好消息要跟你们分享。恭喜。谁是爸爸？没人是爸爸也没人是妈妈。我们今天要诞生一集新节目。什么？对。哦，天哪。
I didn't even know we were pregnant. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh my God. Cigars for everybody. Boy or girl? It's a not, we don't know yet. Oh, gender reveal coming. What, ew, are you about to explode?
我甚至不知道我们怀孕了。对，对，对。哦，天哪。雪茄给每个人。男孩还是女孩？不是，我们还不知道。哦，要办性别揭晓派对啦。什么，额，你快要爆了吗？
Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
欢迎收听 Smartless。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Oh good, he's into the hair. I'm wearing a hat today. Are you going to get a haircut at any point? Are you going to keep letting it get, because I'm going to grow mine out again. I think I'm going to keep going for a little bit for the summer because I'm not really planning on doing too much this summer. You're going to let it be long in the summer. Hang on, Sean, no one's talking yet. Do you want it, don't you want it short
哦太好了，他对头发感兴趣。我今天戴了帽子。你打算什么时候去理发？你还要让它继续长吗，因为我打算把头发再留长一点。我想我夏天打算再留一会儿，因为我今年夏天其实不打算做太多事。你打算让它在夏天留长？等一下，肖恩，还没人说话呢。难道你不想把它剪短吗
during the summer though, Will? Because it's hot? You mean for heat? I know, it does seem counterintuitive. Let me know, let me know when. Sean, can you mute your mic? Sean, he did say, Sean, he did say that we weren't talking to you yet.
夏天的时候，维尔？因为天气热？你是说为了散热？我知道，这听起来确实有点反直觉。告诉我，什么时候告诉我。肖恩，你能把麦克风静音吗？肖恩，他确实说过，肖恩，他确实说过我们还没跟你说话。
I know, no, I know, but let me know. Just give me like a hand signal, or like touch your nose or something. I think that he's gonna get to you, and you'll know when he's ready. I mean, I don't want to I know, but let me know. Just give me like a hand signal or like, touch your nose or something. I think that he's going to get to you and you'll know when he's ready. I mean, I don't want to speak for you, Jason. Okay, so go ahead, but the hair, go ahead with the hair. Yeah, I think, I don't know.
我知道，不，我知道，但你告诉我。只要给我一个手势，或者摸摸鼻子什么的。我想他会轮到你的，而且你会知道他什么时候准备好了。我的意思是，我不想——我知道，但你告诉我。只要给我一个手势，或者摸摸鼻子什么的。我想他会轮到你的，而且你会知道他什么时候准备好了。我的意思是，我不想替你说话，杰森。好吧，那就继续吧，关于头发，继续说头发的事。对，我想，我不知道。
I'm just going to, for the summertime, I'm going to, sorry, thank you, Jason. Sean, even the, yes, don't agree. And even the chuckles. Fuck. Sorry, god. He chuckles, it's a good name. God bless.
我只是打算，为了夏天，我打算，抱歉，谢谢你，杰森。肖恩，连那，是的，别附和。甚至连偷笑也一样。操。抱歉，天哪。他偷笑，这名字挺好。上帝保佑。
Wait, but Will, what would it look like if you cut your hair, it would look so different. Would you ever want to just cut the back? I'll cut it for you. No. How about just cut the top and leave the party in the rear? Oh, no, no, no, I was thinking about, or just going, I want to go for Italian soccer manager,
等等，但是维尔，如果你剪短头发会是什么样，那看起来会有很大不同。你会想过只剪后面吗？我帮你剪。不。不如只剪上面，把派对留到后脑勺？哦，不，不，不，我当时在想，或者干脆，我想走意大利足球教练的风格，
like that guy's Simone Engazi. Tiny Pony? No, no, just kind of like that sort of euro kind of long and then, you know what I mean? No, you look like Javier Bardem in No Country for Old Men. Oh. Well, that's not a compliment. With the hard bands.
就像那个叫西蒙内·因扎吉的家伙。小矮马？不，不，就是那种欧洲风格的长发，然后，你知道我的意思吗？不，你看起来像《老无所依》里的哈维尔·巴登。哦。那可不是什么夸奖。顶着那样的硬刘海。
No, I know. That's not a compliment. No, if you comb it forward, that's what you would look like and you'd shoot people with a cow thing, whatever you did with that thing. What was that thing, yeah. Sean, has your hair ever been crazy? Has it always been what you got?
不，我知道。那不是夸奖。不，如果你把它梳到前面，你看起来就会那样，然后你就会用那个牛铃似的东西去射杀别人，不管你用那个东西干了什么。那是什么东西来着，对。肖恩，你的头发曾经疯狂过吗？它一直都是你现在的样子吗？
My hair has been, what, really long? You know, when I grow it really long, Scotty says every single morning if it's long, he goes, hey, Mav, which is Tom Cruise Maverick in Top Gun. Well, that's a good thing, isn't it? No, I know, but he's like... Does he chase you around the house, is he saying, hey, Tom Cruise Mav? What do you say when you go to Scavo,
我的头发曾经，什么，真的很长吗？你知道的，当我把它留得很长的时候，斯科蒂每天早晨只要看到它很长，就会说，嘿，小牛，也就是《壮志凌云》里汤姆·克鲁斯的那个“小牛”。好吧，那是一件好事，不是吗？不，我知道，但他就像……他会在屋里追着你跑，然后说，嘿，汤姆·克鲁斯小牛？你去斯卡沃的时候，
when you go to Scavo, what do you say? Just give me the accountant? Is that what you say? Wait, did I ever tell you? Give me the CPA? Did I ever tell you, I think I told you this, when I went on tour with Kenny Rogers and... I love his stories.
你去斯卡沃的时候，你会说什么？只要给我一个会计师？你是这么说的吗？等等，我跟你说过吗？给我一个注册会计师？等等，我跟你说过吗，我想我跟你说过这个，当年我和肯尼·罗杰斯一起去巡演的时候……我喜欢他的故事。
I love what the singer is. He's a country western star. When he would call people up during the 12 days The scene of the country western star. When he would call people up there in the 12 days of Christmas from the audience or whatever and this one woman walked up there and she had like big, almost like Princess Leia like things on the side of her head
我喜欢那个歌手是谁。他是乡村西部明星。当他在“圣诞节的十二天”期间打电话给别人时乡村西部明星的场景。当他在“圣诞节的十二天”期间从观众席或什么地方给别人打电话时，有个女人走上台，她的头两侧顶着大大的、几乎像莱娅公主的发髻，
and backstage. Cinnabons. Yeah, Cinnabons. And I was so stoned during that whole tour. Why wouldn't you be? And, it's true, why would not, why wouldn't you be? It's true, why would not, why wouldn't you be?
在后台。肉桂卷。对，肉桂卷。而且我整个巡演期间都嗑嗨了。你为什么不呢？而且，真的，为什么不，为什么你不会呢？真的，为什么不，为什么你不会呢？
By the way, what was he charging per ticket for the Kenny Rogers 12 Days of Christmas? That's a great question. I don't remember, I don't remember. It's probably pretty steep. It was, what was the stadiums? It was like huge. But anyway, I go, I said,
顺便问一下，肯尼·罗杰斯的“圣诞节的十二天”门票他一张收多少钱？这是一个好问题。我不记得了，我不记得了。可能挺贵的。那是，那是什么体育场？简直巨大。但无论如何，我说，
I was backstage acting like I was in the barber, was like huge. But anyway, I go, I said, I was backstage acting like I was in the barber, and I commented on the woman, I go, and I look in the mirror and I go, just Planet of the Apes today, if you can. I said, look, remember the Planet of the Apes? Girl, women had that picture on the side. Yeah, we got it.
我在后台表现得就像在理发店一样，巨大。但无论如何，我说，我在后台表现得好像我在理发店里，然后我对那个女人评头论足，我说，我照着镜子说，如果可以的话，今天就整一个《人猿星球》的造型吧。我说，看，还记得《人猿星球》吗？女孩，女人们脑袋两侧都有那种发型。对，我们懂了。
That's why you laughed. Thank you. It was the laugh was the indicator that we got it. So You don't need to explain, don't sell past the sale. You know what I mean? Sorry, sorry, sorry. Yesterday, Will, I had lunch with our friend. This is from the prepared section of Sean's notes. No, well, it's what really happened yesterday.
这就是你笑的原因。谢谢。笑声就是我们听懂了的指示。所以你不需要解释，别把成交的东西再推销一遍。你知道我的意思吗？抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。昨天，维尔，我和我们的朋友一起吃午饭。这是肖恩笔记里准备好的部分。不，这真的是昨天发生的事。
And I got my tarot cards read for the first time ever. What? Have you ever had that? Yeah, have you ever had, I've never done it. But anyway, so our friend does this for a living, this person that Will and I know, and I got my tarot cards read. But that's the whole story.
我生平第一次去塔罗牌算命。什么？你做过这个吗？对，你做过吗，我从来没做过。但不管怎样，我们的朋友以这个为生，就是维尔和我认识的那个人，我去读了塔罗牌。但这就是全部的故事。
I never had it done before. I don't really remember, but I had a world card, a judgment card, and a guy that was hanged. Like a man. Did you go all in when you saw your hand? No, yeah, exactly. Have you ever had in when you saw your hand? Yeah, no, yeah, exactly. Have you ever had it done? Have you ever been hypnotized?
我以前从没做过。我记不太清了，但我抽到了一张世界牌、一张审判牌，还有一个被绞死的人。就像一个男人。你看到自己手里的牌时，是不是直接梭哈了？不，对，完全是。你以前做过吗？你被催眠过吗？
No. With a stopwatch? I wonder if they still do that. No, I've never been hypnotized. No. I have. Have you, really? Yeah.
没有。伴随着秒表？我不知道他们现在还那样做吗。不，我从来没被催眠过。没有。我被催眠过。你，真的吗？对。
Why? Yeah. I forget what it was. Is it ongoing? No, I snapped out of it a couple hours ago. But this was like, I don't know, 15 years ago. It was part of, I was into some heavy therapy at the time. I was trying to fill some holes
为什么？对。我忘了是为了什么。还在持续中吗？不，我几个小时前刚从催眠中清醒过来。但这大概是，我不知道，15年前的事了。那是，我当时在做一些重度的心理治疗。我试图填补一些空白，
and mend some breaks in my brain. Oh, sure. And it worked, it worked pretty good. I was surprised, because I was pretty skeptical, as one would be, going into hypnotherapy, I think they called it. What was, and can I just, just to get to the nuts and bolts of it,
并修复我大脑中的一些创伤。哦，当然。而且挺管用的，效果相当不错。我很惊讶，因为我挺怀疑的，作为一个进入催眠治疗的人，我想他们是这么叫它的。什么是，我能——为了直奔主题，
what was your involvement? Just showing up, Amanda did everything else, found the person, made the appointment, drove you there. Without a doubt, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, she did everything except just lay me back easy on the sofa.
你参与了什么？就是露面，阿曼达包办了其他所有事，找到了人，预约了时间，把你开车送到那里。毫无疑问，是的。对。对。除了轻柔地把我扶到沙发上躺下之外，她什么都做了。
What, no, and then she was hypnotized. She did everything. Oh, it was her, it was her. But it was, I was very curious, like what would that be? Do you just kind of zonk out? And it was, it basically took me to the place right before you fall asleep. And so I'm in that space and a bunch of memories easily came back.
什么，不，然后她被催眠了。她包办了一切。哦，是她，是她。但那是，我很好奇，那会是什么感觉？你就会那种直接晕过去吗？结果是，它基本上把我带到了你入睡前的那一刻。所以我处在那个空间里，一大堆记忆轻而易举地涌现了出来。
It was like right there at my fingertips and I was able to talk freely about all of these things that I guess are under a layer. See, I would just go straight to sleep. I wouldn't be able to speak. I know, but that's the hypnotherapist talent. They can kind of keep you just like floating right there on the edge, I guess.
它们就像就在我的指尖一样，我可以自由地谈论所有这些我猜是被压在某个层底下的事情。你看，我大概会直接睡着。我根本说不出话来。我知道，但这就是催眠治疗师的本事。我猜，他们能让你刚好漂浮在那个边缘。
And you remembered all of it, as if it, yeah? I guess, yeah. I mean, I did retain some gain from it, I suppose. So yeah, I guess it's a valid form of therapy for sure. Never, I don't think. Much better than getting Delta Hanna cards. I mean, what's going on, Sean? I mean.
而且你把一切都记住了，就像它，对吧？我猜，是的。我的意思是，我确实从中获得了一些收益，我想是的。所以，是的，我猜这绝对是一种有效的治疗方式。绝对没有，我想。比抽德尔塔·汉娜牌好多了。我的意思是，怎么回事，肖恩？我是说。
I thought it was kind of interesting, but I don't really remember any of it. No, the Hanna cards, that is also super valid, and who am I to say what's valid and what's not? Don't walk it back, what are you doing? Yeah, no, I'm just saying. No, are you walking it back? These people. Do you owe somebody money or something?
我觉得这挺有意思的，但我其实什么都不记得了。不，汉娜牌，那也超级有效，而我又算老几，怎么能评判什么是有效的、什么又是无效的呢？别收回你说的话，你在干什么？对，不，我只是说说。不，你是在收回前言吗？这些人。你欠谁钱了吗？
What's going on? Wait, but guys, speaking of hypnotic. Wow. Let's get to it, Sean. Sean, world class, Sean, world class. Yes, thank you, thank you. My guest today studied ballet as a kid, has some legit mime skills, plays the mandolin.
怎么回事？等等，但是伙计们，说到催眠。哇。我们开始吧，肖恩。肖恩，世界级，肖恩，世界级。是的，谢谢，谢谢。我今天的嘉宾小时候学过芭蕾，有一身货真价实的哑剧技能，还会弹曼陀林。
Home alone. No, plays the mandolin. As an actress, she's played a deranged vampire, a real life prosecutor, an actor playing a reporter, a sociopath in outer space, and of course, a dog owner with a lot of feelings. You might not always see her coming, but once once you do she's the only thing you want to watch. Indie Queen, Forever Party Girl, it's a totally original and someone I love
独自在家。不，会弹曼陀林。作为一名演员，她扮演过精神错乱的吸血鬼、现实生活中的检察官、扮演记者的演员、外太空的反社会分子，当然，还有个满腹情感的狗主人。你可能不总能预料到她的出现，但一旦她出现，她就是你唯一想看的人。独立电影女王，永远的派对女孩，她是个完全独一无二的人，也是我深爱的一位
very much. Double P? Parker Posey? I'm just getting out of the... I was hypnotized. I'm just happy to be awake now. Hi fellas. Hi. This is kind of overdue, right? I love your podcast. How have you not been on the show already? Are you sure this isn't your second appearance?
双P？帕克·波西？我刚从……我刚才被催眠了。我只是很高兴现在醒过来了。嗨，伙计们。嗨。这有点迟了吧，对吧？我喜欢你们的播客。你怎么到现在还没上过这个节目？你确定这不是你的第二次亮相吗？
I don't live in Hollywood. Well, you don't have to live in Hollywood to be on the show. I know, but I don't... Well, someone didn't ask me. I don't live in Hollywood either. Just invite me. I just did. I'm in upstate New York, but I don't, someone didn't ask me. I don't live in Hollywood either. Just invite me! I just did! I'm in upstate New York, but I'll come over.
我不住在好莱坞。好吧，你不需要住在好莱坞也能上这个节目。我知道，但我不……好吧，没人邀请我。我也不住在好莱坞。邀请我一下就行。我刚邀请了。我在纽约州北部，但我——没人邀请我。我也不住在好莱坞。邀请我一下就行！我刚邀请了！我在纽约州北部，但我会过去的。
Yeah, it looks like you live in a very handsome apartment there in the West Village, I want to say. Are you in the West Village? It's called the Chateau Marmont, and it's on Sunset. Oh, you are in LA. And when I, yeah, I'm in LA. Actually, out of all of us, you're the only one who's actually in Hollywood right now
对，看起来你住在西村一个非常漂亮的公寓里，我想说。你住在西村吗？这地方叫查托马蒙特酒店，在日落大道上。哦，你在洛杉矶。而且当我，对，我在洛杉矶。事实上，在我们所有人当中，你是唯一一个现在真正身处好莱坞的人
Yeah, as it turns out despite. Where are you guys? elsewhere, you know Wills and see me Valley Sean is Chatsworth. Yeah, and I'm in Brea Sean's in We get a bang for a buck better yeah We get a bang for a buck better. Yeah. Parker, you look gorge. I like the color of your hair. I dyed the hair for a movie I did with Sam Rockwell
对，结果证明尽管如此。你们都在哪？在别的地方，你知道的，维尔和西米谷，肖恩在查茨沃斯。对，我在布雷亚，肖恩在……我们花钱花得更值，对吧？我们花钱花得更值。对。帕克，你看起来美极了。我喜欢你的头发颜色。我为了和山姆·洛克威尔以及
and John Malkovich at Martin McDonough film. Wow. Jesus Christ, I'm so jealous of that film. That cast, that, I mean. Steve Buscemi. But you had to go to South Africa for it, right? Easter Island. Easter Island.
约翰·马尔科维奇一起拍的一部电影染了头发，那是马丁·麦克多纳的电影。哇。天哪，我太嫉妒那部电影了。那个演员阵容，那个，我是说。史蒂夫·布西密。但你得为此去南非，对吧？复活节岛。复活节岛。
Easter Island. They don't know where that is. Rappinoos. It's called Wild for it, right? Easter Island. Easter Island. Easter Island. They don't know where that is. It's called Wild Horse Nine, right? Wild Horse Nine. Easter Island is the furthest place you can go in the world being furthest away from anywhere else. It's a 17 mile island with the heads, with the moai. That's the thing, right.
复活节岛。他们不知道那在哪里。拉帕努伊。这片地方叫狂野马九号，对吧？复活节岛。复活节岛。复活节岛。他们不知道那在哪里。它叫狂野马九号，对吧？狂野马九号。复活节岛是世界上你能去的最偏远的地方，距离其他任何地方都最远。这是一个17英里长的岛屿，上面有人头像，有摩艾石像。就是那个东西，对吧。
The cult of the bird man. It's off the coast of South America. Right. So it's not South Africa, it's South America. No. Yeah. It would be like if you flew from Lima, Peru, and you wanted to go to Sydney, Australia,
鸟人崇拜。它在南美洲海岸附近。对。所以不是南非，是南美。不对。对。这就好比如果你从秘鲁利马起飞，然后你想去澳大利亚悉尼，
you'd fly right over it. Okay, guy, cool it. Yeah, that's smart. Everybody's got property in Portugal. And you're familiar with the Southern hemisphere. It's smart. Wait, she said it. I wasn't. I wasn't. My parents would play a game with me in the car, not property in Portugal. I wasn't.
你就会从它正上方飞过。好了，老兄，冷静点。对，这很聪明。每个人在葡萄牙都有房产。而且你对南半球很熟悉。这很聪明。等等，是她说的。我没有。我没有。我父母以前在车里跟我玩过一个游戏，不是在葡萄牙有房产。我没有。
My parents would play a game with me in the car, and they'd be like, what's the capital of Denver? And I'd do this thing and my grandmother, Nani, she'd have this world, this globe, you know those globes that you would love to spin it. I'm going to go here. And I would just play that for hours. And I'd say, you know what? I'll know where I am when I get there. And if I'm lost and I don't know where I am,
我父母以前在车里跟我玩过一个游戏，他们会问，丹佛的首都是什么？我会做这个动作，而我的祖母，南妮，她会有一个世界，一个地球仪，你知道那种你很喜欢转的地球仪。我要去这里。我就会玩那个玩上好几个小时。然后我会说，你知道吗？我到了那里自然就知道我在哪了。如果我迷路了，不知道我在哪，
I'm going to ask somebody and they're going to tell me. They're going to give directions. And before the phones, I knew where to go and I'd ask people directions and I was fine. Did you come straight from Southeast Asia home, repack your bags and then go to Easter Island or was there a job in between? I'm speaking of the White Lotus show.
我会去问别人，他们会告诉我的。他们会指路的。在手机出现之前，我知道该去哪，我会向别人问路，而且我挺好的。你是直接从东南亚回家，重新打包行李然后去复活节岛，还是中间还有别的工作？说到《白莲花》那个剧。
Oh my God, that's a good question because there's been so much traveling that I wake up in bed and I don't know where I am. It takes me. You need a nice sitcom over at Universal Studios. Thank you. Just relax. Do you know what, you know, I'm really loving Matlock.
哦，天哪，这是个好问题，因为旅行实在太多了，以至于我在床上醒来时都不知道自己在哪。这需要我。你需要在环球影城拍一部不错的肥皂剧。谢谢。放松点。你知道吗，你知道吗，我真的很喜欢《麦克洛克》。
I'm loving Kathy Bates in Matlock. You are? Oh yeah, have you watched it? I bet you could do a nice arc on there. Yeah. Just let them know. Oh, I just like that cozy formula. And she's just fantastic.
我很喜欢凯西·贝茨演的《麦克洛克》。是吗？哦，对，你看过吗？我敢打赌你能在上面客串一个不错的角色。对。让他们知道。哦，我只是喜欢那种温馨的模式。而且她简直棒极了。
And I'm into that. I watched 1923 with Helen Mirren. Oh, yeah. I haven't seen that yet. How was that? It's great. I love the costumes and learning about history and geography and. It sounds like you're good about watching stuff.
我很喜欢那个。我看了海伦·米伦主演的《1923》。哦，对。我还没看过呢。怎么样？太棒了。我喜欢服装，还能了解历史和地理，还有……听起来你很擅长看各种节目。
Are you, do you gobble up everything? See I'm doing all this, this is the awards push of Emmys and you know from White Lotus. I've never been a part of the machine that has you know had that happen. So you're taking a look at the competition? Yeah. Yeah. So. How do you taking a look at the competition? Yeah. Yeah. So.
是不是，你什么都吞得下？看，我正在做这些，这是艾美奖的宣传冲刺，你知道的，为了《白莲花》。我从来没有加入过经历过那种事的机器。所以你在审视竞争对手？对。对。所以。你觉得你的胜算怎么样？
How do you think your chances are holding up? You think Kathy Bates is the horse to beat? I do. Uh-huh. I do. She's the one nominated. She's the horse to beat. I wonder if there's a horse named after her.
你觉得凯西·贝茨是那个最有希望胜出的强敌吗？是的。嗯哼。是的。她是获得提名的那个人。她是那个要超越的强敌。我想知道有没有一匹马是以她的名字命名的。
There's a horse named after me. Is there really? Or there's like a Posey Parker. And yeah, I lived with a woman named Marsha Brill in the West Village. She was an 86 year old, born and bred New Yorker, Jewish lady, who bet on the horses. And she'd go, go ahead, make my day!
有一匹马是以我的名字命名的。真的吗？或者有个叫波西·帕克的。对，我曾在西村和一个叫玛莎·布里尔的女人住在一起。她是一个86岁、土生土长的纽约人，一个犹太老太太，她喜欢赌马。她会说，来吧，成全我吧！
Go get her, make my day! And she would smoke, and she was four foot 11. And my friends would come by and they'd be like, she's fabulous. Like she is like having a stiff drink at five and was an editor. You'd go to the OTB with her or she'd just watch it on the TV?
去抓住她，成全我吧！她会抽烟，身高只有4英尺11英寸。我的朋友们路过时会说，她太棒了。就像在五点钟喝一杯烈性酒一样，而且她曾是个编辑。你会跟她一起去场外投注站（OTB），还是她就在电视上观看？
This was on TV on like a little perfect, you know, black and white little box TV from the 80s downstairs around the kitchen. Amazing. But those times are no longer. But yeah, I'm open to LA. I'm using this podcast for you guys to tell everyone that I'm moving to Hollywood.
这是在电视上看，就在楼下厨房周围那种八十年代的小巧完美的黑白小盒式电视机上。太神奇了。但那些时光一去不复返了。不过是的，我对洛杉矶持开放态度。我正在利用你们这个播客，告诉大家我要搬到好莱坞去。
Truly? No, you're not, are you? But you're not, even if you guys aren't here, you're not in Hollywood. Well, we're in Hollywood, we're not Hollywood. Explain it to me. I'm in the process of moving back to New York, so, you know, I'm going the other way. Is everyone just not, because Julie. I'm going back.
真的吗？不，你不是，对吧？但你不是，即使你们不在这里，你们也不在好莱坞。好吧，我们在好莱坞，我们不是好莱坞。给我解释一下。我正在搬回纽约的过程中，所以，你知道的，我正往反方向走。是不是大家都在，因为朱莉。我要回去了。
You are, okay. I don't really know where to be, and I think that's from being in so many stories, and I should figure it out and stop this like. Wait, but Parker, you've been going back and forth for years and years and years. If you wanted to move out to LA, you would have. But you kind of, you're in both all the time
你要回去了，好吧。我真的不知道该待在哪里，我想那是由于经历过那么多故事，我应该把这弄清楚，然后别再这样了。等等，但是帕克，你来来回回跑了好多年好多年了。如果你想搬到洛杉矶来，你早就搬了。但你某种程度上，你一直都在两边生活，
and all over the world. I'm in a farmhouse. I'm a lady. I'm a steward of the land on this farm in upstate New York. So I couldn't carry both the city and the country. And so now I'm like this. So you got rid of the city.
而且世界各地到处跑。我住在一个农舍里。我是一个女士。我是纽约州北部这个农场里土地的守护者。所以我无法同时兼顾城市和乡村。所以现在我变成了这样。所以你抛弃了城市。
You know, putting bird seed in the feeders. Yeah Really? Well too much. Yeah, I didn't know that's a big good for you So yeah, it's a big switch but like like Hudson Valley type deal. Yeah, the Hudson Valley type deal Oh, wow fucking great. Walty Goggins is close by I just saw him last night. I ran into him He has completed 18 months of nonstop travel and work. He did Fallout, he did Righteous Gemstones, he did White Lotus. And I saw him driving up in the parking lot
你知道的，在喂鸟器里放鸟食。对，真的吗？嗯，太多了。对，我不知道那是很大的，对你有好处。所以，是的，这是一个很大的转变，但就像哈德逊河谷那种类型的。对，哈德逊河谷那种类型的。哦，哇，太棒了。沃尔顿·戈金斯就在附近，我昨晚刚见到他。我碰巧遇到了他。他刚刚完成了18个月不间断的旅行和工作。他拍了《辐射》，拍了《正义宝石》，拍了《白莲花》。我看到他把车开进停车场，
and I was meeting some friends, well, friends were picking me up at 5.35, it was 5.30. Walton drives up and I'm, Walton! And I see him in the car and it's where he like started crying He was like I'm done. I'm done. I just finished all of this, you know mountain of work gets to relax He's got a beautiful house. We've seen it in magazines Yeah, my house isn't like that. My house is really crunchy granola sweet. Yeah But you love it the renovations I'm trying to renovate and get a new kitchen because there's the insulation My house is really crunchy granola sweet. Yeah. I like it.
当时我在跟几个朋友见面，嗯，朋友们本来要在5点35分接我，当时是5点30分。沃尔顿把车开过来，我喊，沃尔顿！我看到他在车里，他甚至哭了。他说，我受够了。我受够了。我刚刚完成了所有这些，你知道的，如山般的工作，终于可以放松了。他有一栋漂亮的我们在杂志上见过的房子。对，我的房子可不那样。我的房子是非常注重环保、温馨的那种。对，但你很喜欢。那些翻修
But you love it. The renovations, I'm trying to renovate and get a new kitchen because there's the insulation, the pipes freeze and all that. And I love a project. But so my house has been this thing that I've, this being, I don't look at my house like mine. I just want to give to it because it's an old farmhouse. So I guess what I'm saying, Will, is like,
但你很喜欢。那些翻修，我正试图翻修并弄一个新的厨房，因为有隔热层的问题，水管会冻裂诸如此类的。我很喜欢搞项目。所以我的房子一直是我一直在，这个存在，我不把我的房子看作是我自己的。我只想为它付出，因为它是一栋老农舍。所以我想说的是，维尔，
and you guys, I'm trying to figure out just where to land in a community. Let's shoot it. Let's shoot it. Let's cover it. Let's shoot the reno of the kitchen. Yeah. We're going to get together with the gang over at Discovery, and they're going to pay for it. Well, I know that's a great idea because,
还有你们，我正试图弄清楚到底要在哪个社区落脚。拍下来。把它拍下来。把它记录下来。把厨房的翻修过程拍下来。对。我们要和探索频道（Discovery）的那帮人碰个头，他们会出资的。好吧，我知道这是个好主意，因为，
and that's what I tell the contractors when they come over, I'm like, I want to, can you, are you open to me filming you with my phone? I would love to do like a home improvement show. I love that. Would you wear this? World, put this on, yeah. Yeah. Dress like you're from 1920.
这也是我告诉那些上门来的承包商的，我说，我想，你能，你介意我用手机拍你吗？我很想做一个家居装修节目。我太喜欢了。你会穿成这样吗？世界，把这个穿上，对。对。打扮得像1920年代的人一样。
Turn around, do the hokey pokey. Dress like you're from 1923. Could you do that? Let's do a period reno. Yes! And get me a hamburger sandwich. Yeah. And then what about,
转过身，跳一段“鸡尾舞”。打扮得像1923年代的人一样。你能做到吗？我们来拍个怀旧风翻修吧。太好了！再给我来个汉堡三明治。对。然后呢，
you, so, and wait, Joe Parker, you also, So I'm pitching all that stuff to like, dead eyes. You told me that, I mean, I read that you like Deval kitchens,
你，所以，等等，乔·帕克，你还，所以我把所有这些东西都推销给那些木头木脑的人。你跟我说过，我的意思是，我读到过你喜欢德沃（Deval）厨房，
because speaking of renovating your place, what's a Deval kitchen? I had to Google it. Deval is loved, spelled backwards. Oh, stupid. Sean, stop it. So stupid. Just throw away my notes.
因为说到翻修你的房子，什么是德沃厨房？我不得不去谷歌了一下。Deval倒过来拼就是loved（被爱）。哦，太蠢了。肖恩，别这样。太蠢了。把我的笔记扔掉吧。
Why don't you just look at the word and you say what it would be backwards. I didn't know it was that, it's not a real thing? Is it a real thing? Spell it loved and put it, go to the mirror. I just did it. Just look at stuff backwards. You did? Yeah, wait, it's a real thing? Is it a real thing? Spell out loved and put it, go to the mirror. I just did it. Look at stuff backwards.
你怎么不直接看那个词，然后说说它倒过来是什么。我不知道那是，这不是个真东西吧？这是个真东西吗？把loved拼出来，然后去照照镜子。我刚才照了。只要把东西倒过来看看。你照了？对，等等，这是个真东西吗？这是个真东西吗？把loved拼出来，然后去照照镜子。我刚刚做了。倒过来看看东西。
We did? Yeah, wait, it's a real thing? DeVoe? Yeah, what the? They had this show on HBO Max called For the Love of Kitchens. And there are these groovy English people in their 50s, our age.
我们做了？对，等等，这是一个真东西吗？德沃？对，怎么回事？他们在HBO Max上有一个节目叫《为了对厨房的热爱》（For the Love of Kitchens）。里面有一群50多岁、和我们年纪相仿的古怪英国人。
And he was making furniture in the 90s and shopping around antique stores and refurbishing this and building that and meeting all these cool guys and making a living and being kind of a vagabond artist and making cool stuff. And that started way back then, right? In the 70s, people were making their own furniture
他在90年代制作家具，逛古董店，翻新这个，建造那个，结识所有这些酷炫的家伙，以此谋生，过着有点像四海为家的艺术家生活，制作很酷的东西。这种风格从很久以前就开始了吧？在70年代，人们自己制作家具，
and the nomadic life stuff and all that. Then it goes out of style and then it came back. But now I think there's a resurgence. People are like, let me see things get fixed and built and give me the reveal. Let me see how it's made. And so I love a reveal. And so, so yeah.
过着游牧生活之类的。然后它过时了，后来又卷土重来。但现在我认为又出现了一股复兴浪潮。人们喜欢看到东西被修理和建造，给我看最后的揭晓时刻。让我看看它是怎么制作的。所以我喜欢揭晓的时刻。所以，是的。
She didn't become a creative director on the show, Deval, until she was in her 40s and her kids were grown. And so there's this partnership, these two people, they're so lovely and have this really beautiful show. And yeah, it's called For the Love of Kitchens. So Deval is their thing. But see, I don't know if I would, I said bye to the renovation because it's so expensive,
直到她40多岁、孩子们都长大成人后，她才成为那个名为Deval的节目的创意总监。所以这里有一种伙伴关系，这两个人，他们非常可爱，而且做了一个非常精彩的节目。是的，它就叫《为了对厨房的热爱》。所以Deval是他们的标志。但是你看，我不知道我会不会，我向翻修说再见了，因为它太贵了，
I should just like sell it and move somewhere else. No, just keep working. Just keep working, just keep making money, and then the price won't matter, right? Just keep pumping. It's different for women. Women don't get paid by the guys. I don't know if you've heard about that.
我应该把它卖掉然后搬到别的地方去。不，只要继续工作。只要继续工作，继续赚钱，然后价格就无所谓了，对吧？继续加油。女人可不一样。女人拿不到跟男人一样的报酬。我不知道你有没有听说过这个。
What? Make a stand. There's a big discrepancy. There's a big discrepancy, darling. There just is. In these little indie movies, you don't make money. But you do an endorsement.
什么？表明立场。这里面有很大的差距。这里面有很大的差距，亲爱的。确实有。在这些小成本独立电影里，你赚不到钱。但你可以接代言。
You should be applauded for, I guarantee you, you've been tempted or offered or presented with some very ugly, low-hanging fruit that you have avoided, right? Some big like, hey Parker, be the star of this big shitty studio movie, and you're like, yeah, I'm good. I like working with cool people on cool things.
你应该受到赞赏，我向你保证，你一定曾经被诱惑过、被提供过或者被摆在眼前一些非常丑陋、唾手可得的好处，而你都避开了，对吧？比如一些大型的，嘿，帕克，来当这部糟糕透顶的好莱坞大片的主演吧，而你会说，不，我挺好的。我喜欢和很酷的人一起做很酷的事情。
Is it true? It's gotta be true. You know, it wouldn't be true now. I'll be honest. I wouldn't do anything right now. It was true when you were younger. It was true. It was true when I was younger.
这是真的吗？这肯定是真的。你知道的，现在可能不是真的了。老实说。我现在什么都不会做。在你年轻的时候是真的。那是真的。在我年轻的时候是真的。
One knowing but. No, it still is true. You know, I had to turn something down that would have paid me a lot of money after White Lotus. And I could barely put a sentence together. I was so wiped from almost seven months of work in Thailand, and what that heavy lift was, and what that long distance run was,
虽说如此，但是……不，现在依然是真的。你知道的，在《白莲花》之后，我不得不拒绝了一笔能让我赚很多钱的邀约。我当时连一句完整的话都快说不出来了。我在泰国经历了近七个月的工作，整个人精疲力竭，那是一次多么沉重的重担，也是一次多么漫长的马拉松，
that it's like, you know, after you go through something, there's like a reverb that I need like three months, three or four months to settle down and get back to myself. It's like- And then they're dangling this big paycheck and still you're like no. And I said, I can't, I can't. Good for you. We'll be right back.
以至于你知道的，当你经历了一些事情之后，会有一种回音，我需要三四个月的时间来沉淀自己并找回自我。这就好比——然后他们晃荡着一张巨额支票，而你依然说不。我说，我不能，我不能。真为你高兴。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. You know, it's amazing, Parker. I remember you, we don't know each other, but I lived in New York in the whole 90s when you were doing all the greatest films. And you're one of those people who's doing the kind of stuff that I wanted to do. Like I just like admire you so much and do continue to.
欢迎回到节目。你知道，这太棒了，帕克。我记得你——我们不认识，但我在整个90年代都住在纽约，当时你正在拍所有那些最棒的电影。你就是那种在做我想做的事情的人。我真的超级崇拜你，而且现在依然如此。
Yeah, still to this day. And we're about the same age, maybe I'm 55, but we're like. You guys both play really young though. I would see you around and stuff and I wasn't working and I was desperately, but I'd see you around in the city and then doing stuff. And we had a lot of mutual, and I'd be like, I just, I want to do what she is doing.
是的，直到今天。而且我们年龄差不多，也许我55岁了，但我们俩就像。不过你们俩演的角色都显得非常年轻。我以前会在周围看到你什么的，当时我没有工作，我非常渴望，但我会看到你在城市里转悠，然后在做各种事情。我们有很多共同点，我会想，我只想做她正在做的事。
Yeah. I want to do work, you're working with great directors, you're working with great performers, you're working with great writers all the time. Like, consistently, year after year, all the films, Kicking and Screaming, Party Girl, whatever, all these great movies that you did. All the Chris Guest stuff.
是的。我想做这样的工作，你一直在和伟大的导演合作，在和伟大的表演者合作，在和伟大的编剧合作。就像，始终如一，年复一年，拍了所有的电影，《轻狂岁月》、《派对女孩》什么的，所有这些你拍的伟大的电影。所有克里斯·吉斯特的电影。
Yeah, and then you add the Chris Guest stuff. I mean, you got to be really proud. You have an incredible body of work. You really do. I just like, but it's, yes, I am, I can't say that I'm proud. That doesn't really, I feel so blessed. I feel so lucky.
是的，再加上克里斯·吉斯特的电影。我的意思是，你一定感到非常骄傲。你有着令人难以置信的作品库。你真的有。我只是觉得，但是，是的，我是，我不能说我很骄傲。那其实不符合，我感到如此受祝福。我感到自己太幸运了。
I mean, this is like. Not lucky, not lucky, fortunate. It's not luck. And fortunate. Good fortune, but it's not luck. I hate to bring it to you. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that is there. Not lucky, not lucky, fortunate. It's not luck. And fortunate. You had good fortune, but it's not luck. I hate to bring it to you. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that is there. I see what you mean.
我的意思是，这就像。不是幸运，不是幸运，是命好。这不是运气。而且命好。运气好，但这不是运气。很抱歉打破你的幻想。对，对，对，确实如此。我明白你的意思。
But yeah, it is a thing. And I mean, I want to write another book. The last seven or eight years have been so, I'm just full of stories, you know? Yeah, I love that. And I know I'm a story maker, and I'm here to share what I'm living and what I'm learning.
但对，这确实是一回事。我的意思是，我想再写一本书。过去七八年里发生了太多事，我心里装满了故事，你知道吗？对，我喜欢这样。而且我知道我是一个故事制造者，我在这里分享我所经历的和正在学习的东西。
Now wait a second listeners, we hate the term storyteller on this show for the obvious reasons. But you just said story maker. I think that's a better word. Story maker. Oh yeah. We're going to allow it.
现在等一下，听众们，我们在这个节目里由于显而易见的原因讨厌“故事讲述者”（storyteller）这个词。但你刚刚说的是“故事制造者”（story maker）。我觉得这是个更好的词。故事制造者。哦，对。我们允许使用这个词。
It's a great fix. Thank you Parker Posey. Parker, I'll tell you why. By the way, you could get away with all of it because you have the credibility. There are too many people now in this town, and by this town I mean LA, and New York, I can consider who have been,
这是一个很棒的修正。谢谢你，帕克·波西。帕克，我告诉你为什么。顺便说一句，你可以随心所欲地使用所有这些词，因为你有这个信誉。现在这个镇上有太多人了——我说的这个镇是指洛杉矶，还有纽约，我可以算上那些曾经——
that term storyteller has become this thing and they refer to themselves as a storyteller. Or like influencers. You deserve it. I barely can do Zoom right now. I've listened to a few of your, I am so feeding the bird feed, putting the seed in the bird feeders. Like I didn't even know the storyteller thing
“故事讲述者”这个词已经变成了一种现象，他们管自己叫故事讲述者。或者像网红一样。你当之无愧。我现在几乎都不会用Zoom。我听了你们的好几个播客，我真的是在喂鸟，把鸟食放进喂鸟器里。我甚至不知道“故事讲述者”这个词
was a thing that people are saying. But think about it, when you hear people say it all the time, you'll go for lunch and people are like, as a storyteller, you're like, you made an episode of a sitcom. Yeah. You're like, fuck off.
是大家都在说的一个梗。但你想想看，当你听到人们整天挂在嘴边时，你去吃午饭，人们会说，作为一名故事讲述者，你会觉得，你不过是拍了一集情景喜剧罢了。对。你会想，滚蛋吧。
Exactly. Like what are you talking about? And why are you referring to yourself in the third person as this abstract object that's full of creativity? Like, go fuck yourself. Right, right. Now you deserve it.
没错。你在胡说八道些什么？你为什么要把自己当成充满创造力的抽象物体用第三人称来指代？去你妈的。对，对。现在你实至名归。
You're sitting in a chair. Yeah. Yeah. Shut up. Like, but you, you're right, Jason's right, and you say story maker, and you are full of stories, and you deserve it, and there's a... Thank you.
你正坐在椅子上。对。对。闭嘴。但是你，你是对的，杰森是对的，你说了“故事制造者”，你满肚子的故事，你当之无愧，而且有一种……谢谢。
Yes, absolutely. You have that, you can back it up. It feels good to be supported by you guys, you know? We got you, girl. My fame hit in the 90s, it's being famous and having that kind of success that I couldn't really explain, and I still don't really understand it. Like, that had older people or...
是的，绝对的。你有这个资本，你撑得起这个称号。听到你们的支持感觉真好，你知道吗？我们挺你，姑娘。我的名气是在90年代打响的，那种成名和随之而来的成功是我无法真正解释的，而且我至今仍无法真正理解。比如，年纪大一点的人或者……
Look at that. That's Sean P. Hayes. That's me and you in 1998. And you had no idea who I was. And I was like, I'm obsessed with Parker Posey. And I grabbed you and I took a photo. And of course, I was in a movie called Billy's Hollywood Screen Kids and I wear the merch like an idiot
看这个。那是肖恩·P·海斯。那是1998年我和你的合影。当时你根本不知道我是谁。而我就像，我迷恋死帕克·波西了。我抓住了你，拍了张照片。当然，我当时在拍一部叫《比利的好莱坞银幕小子》的电影，我还像个傻子一样穿着周边的周边服装。
Are you read that? I was Billy and Billy's Hollywood Screen Kids. Yeah, you were so incredible in that play. Oh, you're Talking about are we talking about stop stop stop? What's the double word one? What's the double? Promise is promise. That's it. That's it. Promise is promise.
你看那个了吗？我就是《比利的好莱坞银幕小子》里的比利。对，你在那部剧里太不可思议了。哦，你在说，我们是在说，停，停，停？那个双重词的是什么？双重的是什么？一言既出，驷马难追。就是这个。就是这个。一言既出，驷马难追。
But then Parker, you're speaking about being famous. But so, but being like, like I just had that photo at the ready because I wanted to show you because that was you at just becoming Parker Posey in the 90s and being labeled the Indie Queen, which did you take that as a- The literal it girl. Yeah, the literal it girl. Did you take that compliment well
但接着，帕克，你刚才谈到成名。但是，所以，当被当作，就像我刚才把那张照片准备好是因为我想拿给你看，因为那是你在90年代刚刚成为帕克·波西、被贴上“独立电影女王”标签的时期，你把这当作一个——字面意义上的It Girl（风云人物）。对，字面意义上的It Girl。你把这个赞美当作好事接受了，
or did you not want that? You know what it is, it's like when people point you out in a place as cool as New York and New York City, and you're not cool anymore. So, it's like, you're, you're, you're, I felt like I was called a name in a way, where I was trying to be, or my path was more like, oh, Greg Mottola did a, youola did a reading of his movie
还是说你其实并不想要这个？你知道是怎么回事，就像当人们在像纽约和纽约市这么酷的地方认出你时，而你已经不再酷了。所以，这就好比，你，你，你，我觉得自己好像被起了一个外号，我的轨迹其实更倾向于，哦，格雷格·莫托拉对他的电影剧本进行了一次剧本围读，
that he was trying to get financed, and then I introduced him to Leav Schreiber, who was in Party Girl, and then we do the Day Trippers a year later, because he couldn't get the original script that he wanted financed, financed, because the budget was too, you know, it was such a community back then.
他当时正试图为这部电影拉投资，然后我把他介绍给了列维·施瑞博尔，他演过《派对女孩》，然后一年后我们拍了《一日游人》，因为他无法为他原本想要的剧本拉到投资，因为预算太，你知道的，那时的社区氛围就是这样。
Right, right, right. And I felt like when it got exposed, right when I got exposed and the whole indie movement got exposed, it also got co-opted by the studio system. And then it became this other thing and all of a sudden, I wasn't viable to get a movie financed and it was such a head trip because, and then I would have to audition for Hollywood movies when I carried the lead
对，对，对。我觉得当它曝光时，就在我曝光、整个独立电影运动曝光的那一刻，它也被好莱坞体制给收编了。然后它变成了另一种东西，突然之间，我再也无法为一部电影拉到投资了，这真是一次精神冲击，因为，后来我不得不去为好莱坞电影试镜，而我明明在那些只拍了23天的独立电影里担纲主角。
in independent movies that were shot in 23 days. And all of a sudden I'm in a fluorescent lit room, like sweating and feeling like I'm being gaslit. You know? Like, I can promise I can do and memorize these lines and the scripts, and I will have a blast. Trust me, you know? Like, I can promise I can do and memorize these lines and these scripts and I will have a blast. Trust me, you know? And I wasn't, so I had like a good 20 years of that,
突然之间我坐在一个荧光灯照亮的房间里，直冒汗，感觉自己被精神虐待了。你知道吗？就像，我向你保证我能做到，我能背熟这些台词和剧本，而且我会玩得很开心。相信我，你知道吗？就像，我向你保证我能做到，我能背熟这些台词和剧本，而且我会玩得很开心。相信我，你知道吗？而我没有，所以我大概有整整20年都处于那种状态，
you know, after, and then working with Great Art Tours and doing these, you know, not getting paid a lot, but being able to, you know, work in the world. Wealthy with respect. Yeah, my creativity. And feeling satisfied, I imagine. Yeah, it's a weird thing. It's like, it's a mystical thing.
你知道的，在那之后，然后和伟大的艺术大师合作，做这些，你知道的，片酬不高，但能够，你知道的，在世界上工作。带着尊严致富。是的，我的创造力。而且我猜也感到了满足。对，这是一种奇怪的事情。这就像是一种神秘的事情。
I think my life and people's lives can have a mystical kind of quality if they're paying attention of like, and I think it's a healing thing. I think I evolve, I grow, I'm kind of a hippie like that. Well let me ask you this, are you at a spot in your career, and then we're gonna talk about your personal life, that's gonna be great, that's gonna be a whole
我认为我的人生以及人们的人生如果他们足够留心的话，都可以有一种神秘的特质，而且我认为这是一件具有治愈作用的事。我认为我在进化，在成长，我就是那种嬉皮士。那让我问你这个，你现在处于职业生涯的什么阶段，接下来我们要聊聊你的个人生活，那会很棒，那会是一次彻底的
lighting change, you know what I mean? But professionally, are you at a place right now that you had the balls to even imagine and dream and hope for? Is this the career you thought you were going to have or the career that you hoped that you had? There's a lot there. Wow, that's a lot, JB. What the fuck, man?
灯光变换，你知道我的意思吗？但就专业而言，你现在的处境达到了你当初甚至有胆量去想象、去梦想、去期望的地步吗？这就是你以为自己会拥有的职业生涯，还是你一直希望拥有的职业生涯？这里面包含的内容可真多。哇，这信息量真大，JB。搞什么鬼，老兄？
It's early. That's a good question. You know, when you do a lot of traveling and you're not home, I haven't been home for more than five days since February. Right. It's so much more interesting than your career or where you thought you would be in as far as like,
这才刚开始呢。这是个好问题。你知道，当你到处旅行却不在家时。自从2月份以来，我在家呆的时间就没有超过五天。对。这可比你的职业生涯或者你以为自己能达到的高度要有趣得多，就比如《白莲花》这样的作品带给你的成功，对吧？
at the success that something like White Lotus gives you, right? Right. That I feel so blessed, I feel so protected. I feel in my flow, and that is, I feel like I've learned, I've been through a lot. From 45 to 56 was a lot. What do you mean, what's a lot?
对。我感到自己如此受祝福，我感到自己受到了保护。我感觉自己进入了心流状态，那就是，我觉得我学会了，我经历了很多。45岁到56岁这段时间经历了太多。你是什么意思，经历了太多是指什么？
Like good or challenging? My dad had prostate cancer for 20 years from Agent Orange in Vietnam. Oh, I'm sorry. I'm talking like a prolonged grief, like an anticipatory grief. I think I had a lot of grief with my career and going like, I don't quite understand it.
是指好的方面还是充满挑战？我父亲因为越南战场的橙剂患了20年前列腺癌。哦，我很遗憾。我说的是一种延长的悲伤，就像一种期待性悲伤。我想我对我的职业生涯也有过很多悲伤，心里想着，我有点搞不懂它。
As a woman, you get older and then, and the culture changes, so you have that and you You have good ideas that you pitch that are educational and and kids would love them and they don't get made You know, there's a lot of disappointment in the in the culture right now Now more than ever now more as an artist and you're just kind of, but this is such a powerful medium, I don't understand why more is being on the screen. If the arts are going to be subsidized in New York, is it going to be the apex of creativity, then what can we make to form something that will be that
作为女性，你变老了，然后文化也变了，所以你经历了这些，你提出了很好的、具有教育意义的想法，孩子们会很喜欢，但它们却没有被拍成电影。你知道的，现在文化中有很多失望。现在比以往任何时候都多，现在作为一个艺术家，你只能，但这是一个如此强大的媒介，我不明白为什么屏幕上不能有更多这样的内容。如果艺术要在纽约获得资助，如果它将成为创造力的巅峰，那么我们能创造出什么来形成能够体现这种精神的东西
and will hold that for our playwrights, for our writers who are born to tell, that have that soul. And I've read enough scripts and I've seen enough plays to know that there is that divine spark when you read something that is like our town or something that is so, and we used to be a culture that aimed toward that.
并为我们的剧作家、那些生来就是为了讲述、拥有那种灵魂的作家们坚守这一点。我读过足够多的剧本，也看过足够多的戏剧，我知道当你读到像《我们的小镇》那样或诸如此类有神圣火花的作品时，我们曾经是一个朝着这个目标努力的文化。
And I hope, I'm an optimist, I will be that, to Moscow, to Moscow, check off character till the day I die. I believe in, being in Thailand for so long and coming back to America was so inspiring. I mean, everyone, I'm like, ugh, you know? I'm like, this country and these people and these trees and this nature,
我希望，我是个乐观主义者，我会一直这样，向莫斯科，向莫斯科，直到我死的那一天，我都扮演着契诃夫的角色。我相信，在泰国呆了那么久然后回到美国，真的太鼓舞人心了。我的意思是，每个人，我都觉得，呃，你知道吗？我就会觉得，这个国家，这些人，这些树木，这大自然，
like, do you know how lucky we are? Like, we kind of like shape up in like this way that has been so. What would you do, now that you sit here, I love hearing you talk. Is that too much tooting my horn? Like, is that an octopus? Are you kidding?
就像，你知道我们有多幸运吗？就像，我们以这种方式组合在一起，真是太……既然你坐在这里，你觉得该怎么办，我喜欢听你说话。我是不是有点太自吹自擂了？就像，那是章鱼吗？你在开玩笑吧？
I love that. I love everything you said. If you had 20 more minutes on that. Wait, did you everything you said. If you had 20 more minutes on that. Wait, did you just toot? If you had 20 more minutes on that, we would be good. Yeah. Having said all that, when you sit, so sitting where you are today with all that information,
我喜欢那样。我喜欢你说的所有话。如果你在这上面再多花20分钟。等等，你把你说的都……如果你在这上面再多花20分钟。等等，你刚刚放屁了吗？如果你在这上面再多花20分钟，我们就好了。对。话虽如此，当你坐着，所以结合你今天所处的位置以及所有这些信息，
like having all that stuff and you tooted, would you, what would you, is there anything that you would have done differently? Was there a moment? Was there a thing? is there something you look back on and go, ah. She just tutored. You know what I mean? So stupid. Would you have done anything differently? Well I know because you're just all learning about, you know, you're changing and you're like, I mean, I think I
就像拥有所有这些东西，然后你放了个屁，你会，你会，有什么事情是你觉得如果能重来会做得不同的吗？有没有那么一个时刻？有没有那样一件事？有没有什么事你回过头去会想，啊。她刚刚放屁了。你知道我的意思吗？太蠢了。你有没有什么事是希望当时能做得不一样的？好吧，我知道，因为你正在了解，你知道，你在改变，然后你觉得，我的意思是，我觉得我
could have been easier on myself. I think I could have not worked so hard and I could have deserved more and. Or felt like you were deserving more, you mean? Yes, that's right. But wait, but Parker, I want to go through things in your life that kind of, I read about that fascinating me. I didn't know you were a mime, you were trained in mimes.
本可以对自己的要求更轻松一些。我觉得我本可以不用那么拼命，我本可以值得拥有更多，还有。或者觉得你本来就配得上更多，你是这个意思吗？是的，没错。但是等等，帕克，我想聊聊你生活中那些，我读到过并且觉得很着迷的事情。我不知道你曾是个哑剧演员，你受过哑剧训练。
That was a lie. A mime training? That was a total lie. me. I didn't know you were a mime. You were trained in mime. And that was a lie. A mime training? That was a total lie. Oh, I didn't know that. God, I was like, I had to put a resume and I'm a fan, but I saw Marcel Marceau in New York, like on his 80th birthday perform. And I cried my face off.
那是个谎言。哑剧训练？那完全是个谎言。我。我不知道你是个哑剧演员。你受过哑剧训练。那是个谎言。哑剧训练？那完全是个谎言。哦，我不知道那个。天哪，我当时想，我得写一份简历，我是个粉丝，但我在纽约看马塞尔·马索表演，好像是在他80岁生日的时候。我哭得稀里哗啦。
Because you thought it was amazing that he was moving boxes that weren't there. Yes. Yes. his 80th birthday, perform, and I cried my face off. Because you thought it was amazing that he was moving boxes that weren't there. Yes. Yes. I've never, now where has mine? It's just anything that can reach like a four year old and a hundred year old, like what that did,
因为你觉得他能演出那些根本不存在的箱子，这太神奇了。是的。是的。在他80岁生日的时候表演，我哭得稀里哗啦。因为你觉得他能演出那些根本不存在的箱子，这太神奇了。是的。是的。我从来没有，现在哑剧在哪里？这只是一种能触及四岁小孩和百岁老人的艺术，那种感觉，
it was just so artful and fantastic. Jason has a question about mine. I'm not making fun of mine, you're not getting me to make fun of mine, but I lied about it on my resume. No, but is it still going? Because I feel like it's so resume. Is it still going? I feel like it's so sort of kitsch now that you could actually make a run at it.
它就是那么充满艺术感又奇妙。杰森对哑剧有个问题。我不是在取笑哑剧，你别想让我取笑哑剧，但我在简历上撒了谎。不，但它还在继续吗？因为我觉得它现在有点太媚俗了，你其实完全可以去尝试一下。
If you had, if anyone out there has some mime skills, I bet you could really make yourself a nice living nowadays because it's kind of ironic and you could probably pack some theaters, some large theaters, maybe not arenas, but I think you could do a theater tour. Is it still going? What about MIME? I mean, your overhead's low, you need something black. Something black and tight. No props, you're not allowed props.
如果你有，如果外面有谁有点哑剧技能，我敢说你现在真的能靠这个过上不错的生活，因为它有点带讽刺意味，你可能还能撑满一些剧院，一些大型剧院，也许不是体育馆，但我觉得你可以搞个剧院巡演。它还在继续吗？哑剧呢？我的意思是，你的固定成本很低，你只需要穿黑色的东西。黑色的紧身衣。不准用道具，不允许带道具。
No words, no words either. Go get after it. You need a spotlight. Just a stripy t-shirt and a spotlight. And some leggings. Yeah, I'd go see a MIME show. Okay, so wait, so Parker, you were named after the model Suzy Parker, correct? Yeah, there are two parts of the story.
没有台词，也没有台词。去干吧。你需要一个聚光灯。一件条纹T恤和一个聚光灯。还有打底裤。对，我会去看哑剧表演的。好吧，等等，那么帕克，你是用模特苏茜·帕克的名字命名的，对吧？对，这个故事有两个部分。
They did love, my parents, you know, fell madly in love and married young and my dad was drafted and the twins were born. Yeah, you have a twin brother, which I didn't know about, you have a twin brother, which I didn't know about. I have a twin brother. And my mom had a friend when she was a little girl,
我父母确实很相爱，你知道的，他们疯狂坠入爱河并很年轻就结婚了，我爸爸被征召入伍，然后双胞胎就出生了。对，你有一个双胞胎兄弟，我之前不知道，你有一个双胞胎兄弟，我之前不知道。我有一个双胞胎兄弟。我妈妈在她还是个小女孩的时候有一个朋友，
who, my mom was 12, like 11 or 12, like still a Girl Scout, and one of her friends had, her sister had a baby and named her Parker, and my mom, whose name is Linda with a Y, she always hated it. Linda with a Y. Why does my mother, Linda with a Y?
那个，我妈妈当时12岁，大概11或12岁，还在当女童军，她其中一个朋友的，她姐姐生了个孩子，取名叫帕克，而我妈妈，她的名字叫琳达（Linda），带一个Y，她一直很讨厌这个名字。带Y的琳达。为什么我妈妈是带Y的琳达？
And she goes, oh, there's a little butterfly outside. No way, let's stop for a second. And so my mom said, if I ever have a little girl, I'm going to give her a strong name like Parker. And so my mom said if I ever have a little girl, I'm going to give her a strong name like Parker. But then she met my dad with this name like Posey and I almost died at birth. My dad was like there in this army. Wait, wait, let's not gloss over that.
然后她说，哦，外面有一只小蝴蝶。不会吧，我们停一下。于是我妈妈说，如果我以后生个小女孩，我要给她起一个像帕克这样坚强的名字。于是我妈妈说如果我以后生个小女孩，我要给她起一个像帕克这样坚强的名字。但后来她遇到了我爸爸，他的名字叫波西（Posey），我出生时差点夭折。我爸爸当时就在那个军队里。等等，等等，我们别把这个轻描淡写地带过。
Hang on a second. Slow, yeah. We stop for the butterfly, but you don't stop for the dolphin. But you plow through the death? Yeah. Were you plow through the death? Were you almost dropped? Or was it a... What happened?
等一下。慢点，对。我们为蝴蝶停下，但你们不为海豚停下。但你们却对死亡轻描淡写？对。你们对死亡轻描淡写吗？你差点被抛弃吗？还是说……发生了什么？
Were you still in the oven? I was still in the oven. I was born premature. And a week before, on Halloween, my mom got the news that she was having twins. And so the story was that I was in her ribs and they didn't even know where I was. So I was out at three pounds. Like Eve speaking the Bible, right? Like Eve came from Adam's rib.
你还在肚子里吗？我还在肚子里。我早产了。就在前一周，万圣节那天，我妈妈得到消息说她怀的是双胞胎。所以当时的说法是，我躲在她的肋骨里，他们甚至不知道我在哪里。所以我出来的时候只有三磅重。就像《圣经》里夏娃说话一样，对吧？就像夏娃是从亚当的肋骨里出来的一样。
Yeah, there you go. Wow. It's all coming together. And so, yeah, I was like not even three pounds. And so the doctor I was like not even three pounds and And so the doctor came in I'm saying your your boy is fine, but we don't know about your girl. We need a name So we're just gonna park her right here Right here and what's the middle name and my middle middle name is Christian because they wanted the help of Jesus and God and anyone else who would listen.
对，就是这样。哇。这一切都串联起来了。所以，对，我甚至连三磅都没有。然后医生——我甚至连三磅都没有，然后医生走进来，我说你的男孩很好，但女孩我们不知道。我们需要一个名字，所以我们就把她“帕克（Park）”在这里，就在这儿，中间名是什么？我的中间名是克里斯蒂安（Christian），因为他们想要耶稣、上帝以及任何愿意倾听的人的帮助。
And so, yeah, my dad would tell this story. That he was in the hospital with a six pack of beer, like kneeling and praying as he's like looking at me in an incubator with these, and he's like, please God, please let my little girl live, and at that moment I screamed. No way. Oh wow.
所以，对，我爸爸会讲这个故事。说他当时在医院里，手里拿着一罐六联装啤酒，一边跪着祈祷，一边看着保温箱里的我，他说，求求上帝，求求你让我的小女孩活下来，就在那个时候我尖叫了。不会吧。哦，哇。
So I was like, okay, now my dad talks to God all the time. So it was such a crazy story to tell a little kid, and how you tell, so I got a lot of that mythologizing. Yeah, that's cool though. As a kid, which I, and then he also said, and I looked at that beer can and I said, my girl is the size of this beer can. She's like a beer can with legs.
所以我当时就想，好吧，现在我爸爸经常跟上帝说话。所以给一个小孩子讲这样一个疯狂的故事，以及你是怎么讲的，所以我吸收了很多那种神话色彩。对，不过这挺酷的。作为一个小孩子，我觉得，然后他还说，我看着那个啤酒罐，然后我说，我的女孩就和这个啤酒罐一样大。她就像一个长着腿的啤酒罐。
And that was like, I was like, and look at me now. So. Were you treated like the golden child, because you kind of like, against all odds, you kind of came to life and all that stuff? No, no, no, no. I think that's often the case, isn't it? Like sometimes people are.
当时我就觉得，再看看现在的我。所以。你有没有被当成金童玉女对待，因为你某种程度上，在历经千难万险后，你算是活过来了诸如此类的？不，不，不，不。我想通常情况都是这样的，不是吗？有时候人们就是会。
I mean, I was definitely daddy's girl. My dad I describe as a comedian without a venue. He was really funny and really a performer. Tell me about that time, about your dad calling, you were in the summer program, I didn't know you were in ballet. I was a ballerina and my dad, I auditioned, I went away when I was 12 for North Carolina School of the Arts to dance, and I loved ballet.
我的意思是，我绝对是爸爸的女孩。我形容我爸爸是一个没有场地的喜剧演员。他真的很有趣，也很有表演天赋。跟我讲讲那段时光，关于你爸爸打电话的事，你当时在参加夏令营，我不知道你学过芭蕾。我曾是一名芭蕾舞演员，我爸爸——我12岁时离开家去北卡罗来纳艺术学院学跳舞，我非常热爱芭蕾。
And I auditioned for the dance program, and I didn't get in, and I was devastated. And my dad called the dean of the school, and he said, my daughter's going to be devastated. What do I tell her? And he said, we loved her so much, and she almost got in, because she's so much fun. But you just tell her she's an actress, and that's how it all started. Oh, for real?
我去舞蹈专业试镜，结果没被录取，我当时心碎了。我爸爸给学校的院长打电话，他说：“我女儿要心碎了。我该对她说什么？”院长说：“我们太喜欢她了，她差一点就被录取了，因为她太有趣了。但你就告诉她她是个演员。”一切就是这样开始的。哦，真的吗？
No way. Really? Yeah. And so I went back to NCSA for acting, and it was there I did clowning, and maybe that's why I made fun of Mime back then. But I have respect for Mime, and I appreciate Mime. And I did movement and dance and all of that.
不会吧。真的吗？对。于是我又回到了NCSA学表演，也就是在那里我学了小丑表演，也许这就是为什么我当时会取笑哑剧。但我对哑剧充满敬意，我也很欣赏哑剧。我还学了形体、舞蹈以及所有这些。
And... So where did you grow up? Where was your childhood? Monroe, Louisiana. Oh, really? Born in Baltimore, raised in Louisiana, and then Mississippi. That's right. We moved to Laurel when I was 12. So I was already like out the door. What was your first pro gig?
然后……那你是在哪里长大的？你的童年是在哪里度过的？路易斯安那州门罗。哦，真的吗？出生在巴尔的摩，在路易斯安那州长大，后来又去了密西西比州。没错。我12岁时我们搬到了劳雷尔。所以我当时就已经算是离家出走了。你的第一份专业工作是什么？
It was a short... I was a junior in college and was a short called first love fatal love for HBO about a woman and a young person in high school Who had AIDS and this was played by a woman named Alex Odair. I love it adore She's Gabby Hoffman's older sister and she's just brilliant and a great person and woman, and she wrote a book too, she's just wonderful. And Steve Zahn, Steve Zahn had 10 lines in that, I had 10 lines, and I had 10 lines. I was 20, I think.
是一个短片……我上大学三年级时拍的一个短片，是为HBO拍的，叫《初恋，致命爱》，讲的是一个女人和高中一个患有艾滋病的年轻人之间的故事，那个年轻人由一个叫亚历克斯·奥代尔（Alex Odair）的女人扮演。我太喜欢她、太崇拜她了。她是加比·霍夫曼（Gabby Hoffman）的姐姐，她简直才华横溢，是个非常棒的人和女性，她还写过书，她真是太棒了。还有史蒂夫·赞恩（Steve Zahn），史蒂夫·赞恩在那里面有10句台词，我也有10句台词，我有10句台词。我当时20岁，我想。
And then what, and then you did that, you graduated from, where were you? What about you, I want to hear like little stories, like when did that all click for you guys? No, but how'd you get to New York? No, to hear like little stories like when did that all click for you guys? No, but when, how did you get to New York? No, no, you're in the chair. You're in the chair.
然后呢，然后你拍了那个，你从哪里毕业的，你当时在哪？那你呢，我想听听一些小故事，比如这一切对你们来说是什么时候开窍的？不，但你是怎么去纽约的？不，是听一些小故事，比如这一切对你们来说是什么时候开窍的？不，但是什么时候，你是怎么去纽约的？不，不，你坐在椅子上。你坐在椅子上。
So when did you move to New York? So at NCSA when I was there at 16, because I went for the summer programs and I just loved it, one of the teachers there named Molly, she had this big cow, she was a modern dance teacher and she had this big cow patty bun on her head and wore like, you know. Cow patty bun. Leotards and character skirts all day long. She'd been wearing them for like 35 years, right?
那你是什么时候搬到纽约的？所以在NCSA，我16岁在那儿的时候，因为我是去参加夏令营，我太喜欢那儿了，那儿有个老师叫莫莉，她头上顶着一个大大的牛粪髻，她是个现代舞老师，头上顶着一个大牛粪髻，穿着，你知道的。牛粪髻。整天穿着紧身衣和角色裙。她那样穿了大概有35年了吧，对吧？
Love them. And I love the modern dance teachers. She said, you know, you may want to try auditioning for SUNY Purchase for drama. And because these schools accept different types of actors. And so I auditioned for NCSA, Juilliard, and SUNY Purchase. And Purchase was the school I got into. That's amazing. Wow.
太喜欢了。我太喜欢现代舞老师了。她说，你知道，你可能想去试镜纽约州立大学帕切斯学院（SUNY Purchase）的戏剧专业。因为这些学校接受不同类型的演员。所以我去试镜了NCSA、朱莉亚学院和帕切斯学院。帕切斯就是我被录取的学校。太棒了。哇。
And your roommate was sharing. And I was going to, I was living in New York City the June in 1989, 90 of my junior year. And freelancing with a manager, I know, gosh, it's wild to think about how long I've been doing this. That was the year I moved to New York, 90. Wow. Same year.
你的室友在分享。我当时要，1989年、1990年我大三的那年6月，我住在纽约市。和一个经纪人做自由职业者，我知道，天哪，一想到我已经干这行这么久了，就觉得好疯狂。那是我搬到纽约的那一年，90年。哇。同一年。
Where did you live? Everywhere. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Parker, you've talked a lot about your, you know, you described your family as like these fabulous southern characters that you emulate sometimes and stuff.
你住在哪里？到处都是。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。帕克，你之前聊了很多关于你的，你知道的，你把你的家庭形容为那些你有时会模仿的传奇南方人物之类的。
Like what is your favorite things to go to when creating characters that emulate your family? Like a lot of my Midwestern stuff, like I do that too. We call pop instead of soda. There's Portillo's, which is a very popular Midwestern chain. Obviously the pizza. This is insane character work you're doing.
比如你在创作模仿你家人的角色时，最喜欢用哪些梗？就像我很多中西部的东西，我也会那样做。我们把苏打水叫pop。还有Portillo's，这是一个非常受欢迎的中西部连锁店。显然还有披萨。你这角色塑造得太疯狂了。
I just want to, just as a quick aside, how do you... Anything above 50 degrees. How do you keep track of it all? Just as a quick aside. Where did you train? Anything above 50 degrees. Are you in character now? Who are we talking to? Who are we talking to right now?
我只是想，顺便问一下，你是怎么……任何高于50度的时候。你是怎么把这些都记住的？顺便问一下。你在哪儿受的训？任何高于50度的时候。你现在是在角色里吗？我们在和谁说话？我们现在是在和谁说话？
I know, I got to chat. I got to go to zero. So Soda, you call Pop. Pop, yes, hang on. 50 degree. Can I get a pen? I'm gonna get a pen. I'm gonna get a pen. I'm gonna get a pen.
我知道，我得聊聊。我得降到零。所以苏打水，你们叫Pop。Pop，对，等一下。50度。能给我一支笔吗？我要拿一支笔。我要拿一支笔。我要拿支笔。
I'm gonna get a pen. Cinnamon rolls with chili is very Midwestern. I put ketchup on steak. My mom used to say, like, my mom used to say. What if you were to play somebody from the Northeast? Who, me or Parker? Yeah, what are you putting on your steak then? Yeah, no, Sean.
我要拿一支笔。带辣椒的肉桂卷非常中西部。我在牛排上加番茄酱。我妈妈以前常说，就像，我妈妈以前常说。如果你要扮演一个东北地区的人会怎么样？谁，我还是帕克？对，那你会在牛排上加什么？对，不，肖恩。
Sean, what would you call soda then? I don't know what they call it. Seltzer, Parker? Yeah, what are you putting in your steak then? No, Sean. What would you call soda then? I don't know what they call it. Seltzer. Right? Seltzer. Oh, do they call it seltzer? Now you're in it. Don't they call soda in the South?
肖恩，那你管苏打水叫什么？我不知道他们叫它什么。苏打水（Seltzer），帕克？对，那你会在牛排上加什么？不，肖恩。那你管苏打水叫什么？我不知道他们叫它什么。苏打水（Seltzer）。对吧？苏打水。哦，他们管这叫苏打水吗？你现在彻底进入状态了。南方人不把苏打水叫……吗？
If you were in the South, you'd call everything a Coke. That's right. No matter what. Coke. Anyway, I didn't know if there was any. Yeah, the South is a different, you know, I just, yeah. Did you read plays? Did everyone read plays as a young actor?
如果你在南方，你把什么都叫Coke（可乐）。没错。不管是什么。Coke。总之，我不知道有没有。对，南方是个很不一样的，你知道的，我只是，对。你读过戏剧吗？年轻演员都会读戏剧吗？
Yeah, always, yeah. I didn't. So it's that, well you were already on that TV show, Jason. Dumb stuff, yes. How cute were you on that little show? I mean, pretty cute. I was like, he's cute. He's really cute, he's very cute.
对，总是读，对。我没有。所以就是那个，好吧，你当时已经在那部电视剧里了，杰森。蠢事，对。你在那个小节目里多可爱啊！我的意思是，挺可爱的。我当时就想，他挺可爱的。他真的很可爱，非常可爱。
He's still very cute. Very cute. Don't kid yourself. Let's go slow through this section. Okay, so listen, then Parker, I want to go through your hobbies, if it's okay to call them hobbies. Pottery, sewing, Ashtanga yoga, which I have no idea what that is.
他现在依然很可爱。非常可爱。别自欺欺人了。我们在这个环节慢一点。好吧，听着，然后帕克，我想了解一下你的爱好，如果把这些称为爱好的话。陶艺，缝纫，阿斯汤加瑜伽（Ashtanga yoga），我完全不知道那是什么。
Ashtanga. Ayurvedic medicine, I have no idea what that is. Like, what are all those things? Stupid. That's so stupid. Oh! is like what are all those things? Oh my god. What are those things? What's Ayurvedic? Is that it?
阿斯汤加。阿育吠陀医学（Ayurvedic medicine），我完全不知道那是什么。比如，所有这些都是些什么东西？太蠢了。太蠢了。哦！就像那些都是什么东西？天哪。那些都是什么东西？什么是阿育吠陀？就是那个吗？
Okay, Ayurvedic. When I was doing, I did a movie called The Eye with Jessica Alba and it was based on a Korean film. Yay Jessica. It was based on a Korean film, a horror film, about a woman who's blind and gets a chance to see. I'll be honest, I never saw it. And so she, my sister, Jessica gets her eyes,
好吧，阿育吠陀。我当时在拍一部电影叫《夺命眼》（The Eye），和杰西卡·阿尔芭（Jessica Alba）合作，它是根据一部韩国电影改编的。太棒了杰西卡。它改编自一部韩国恐怖片，讲的是一个盲人女性获得了重见光明的机会。说实话，我从来没看过。所以她，我妹妹，杰西卡得到了她的眼睛，
gets a surgery where she gets these eyes back and they're the eyes of a murderer. And it was a great part as her sister because all I had to do is like, what's going on, you seem different. And I was in New Mexico for like three weeks. And I went to the Ayurvedic Institute and I sat in on some classes with an Ayurvedic teacher named dr. Vasant lad who is like one of these leading Ayurvedic
做了一个手术，换回了这些眼睛，而这些眼睛属于一个杀人犯。作为一个姐姐，这是一个很棒的角色，因为我只需要说，怎么了，你看起来有点不一样。我在新墨西哥州呆了大约三周。我去了阿育吠陀研究所，旁听了一些由一位名叫瓦桑特·拉德（Dr. Vasant Lad）的阿育吠陀老师的课，他是全国领先的阿育吠陀专家之一
People in the country and if you know Andrew while I think his name is or with the with the big gray beard Yeah, that guy and so you know about it. Yeah And I sat in on some classes at the institute there, and I met this, I hung out at the Annapurna Cafe, which is like the Indian cafe, and found the yoga classes, but heard from this guy Prakash that there was a, there was an Ayurvedic school, and I should go,
业内人士，如果你知道安德鲁·韦尔（Andrew Weil）的话，我想他叫这个名字，就是那个长着大灰胡子的家伙，对，就是那个人，所以你对这个有所了解。对。我在那里的研究所旁听了一些课程，我还遇到了这个，在安娜普尔纳咖啡馆（Annapurna Cafe）闲逛，那是一家印度咖啡馆，找到了瑜伽课，不过是从一个叫普拉卡什（Prakash）的家伙那里听说，那里有一个阿育吠陀学校，我应该去看看，
because this Dr. Vasant Mahat is incredible. So I sat in on some classes there. It was really cool. What do they teach? What is Ayurvedic? It's a science. It's a science of the body and like we're born into these bodies that tell us what our psychology is and what our diet, how we should eat. And then there's three different, there's pitta, vata, and kapha. So everyone falls into these different categories of, I burn through energy.
因为这位瓦桑特·马哈特（Dr. Vasant Mahat）博士太不可思议了。所以我去那里旁听了一些课程。真的很酷。他们教什么？什么是阿育吠陀？这是一门科学。这是一门关于身体的科学，就像我们生来就拥有这些身体，它们告诉我们我们的心理是怎样的，我们的饮食是什么样的，我们应该如何饮食。然后有三种不同的体质，皮塔（pitta）、瓦塔（vata）和卡法（kapha）。所以每个人都属于这些不同的类别，我消耗能量很快。
You know, like when I'm working, I'm quick to grasp things, but I can easily forget them. And so it's like a way of your body, you're designed in a certain way. We're incarnated into these bodies to have this kind of experience, and with these bodies, they are teaching us
你知道的，当我在工作时，我很快就能理解事物，但我很容易忘记它们。所以这就像是你身体的一种方式，你是以某种特定方式被设计的。我们转世投胎进入这些身体来获得这种体验，通过这些身体，它们在教导我们
how to be centered and aligned and open. And there's certain programs that benefit each type of body. That's right, yeah, and certain foods. So there were people who had cancer who did the Ayurvedic. There's a, it's called Pachakarma, I think. That's interesting, I'm not really into that.
如何保持中心、对齐和开放。并且有特定的方案对每种类型的身体都有益。没错，是的，还有特定的食物。所以有些人患有癌症，他们尝试了阿育吠陀。有一个，好像叫“排毒疗法”（Pachakarma）。这很有趣，我其实对这个不太感冒。
It's really interesting. And through diet, they've healed themselves. And then they're like, okay, we're opening a restaurant in Hawaii and I'm going to serve Ayurvedic food because this is healing people more than my chemo did. So when my dad had cancer, I tried to get him to be more, to be healthier. And I saw someone sent me a doc called,
这真的很有趣。通过饮食，他们治愈了自己。然后他们就会说，好吧，我们要去夏威夷开一家餐馆，我要提供阿育吠陀食物，因为这比我的化疗更能治愈人们。所以当我的爸爸得了癌症时，我试图让他变得更健康一些。我看到有人给我发了一部纪录片，
I think Surviving Cancer, which had an interview of all these people who said, I'm not doing chemo, I'm just going to see what happens with my diet and then I change it. And anyway, it's kind of, I like all that stuff. I've met two people in my life who, in the last 20 years, who had different forms of cancer, who did similar things, who changed not just their diet,
好像叫《战胜癌症》，里面采访了所有这些说“我不做化疗，我只是想看看改变饮食会发生什么，然后我改变了”的人。不管怎样，这挺，我喜欢所有这些东西。我在生活中遇到过两个人，在过去的20年里，他们患有不同形式的癌症，他们做了类似的事情，不仅改变了饮食，
but their lifestyle, removed stress, and did all that stuff, and were able to completely eliminate the cancer. This one guy had been a firefighter and he developed lung cancer, true story. And he ended up being, JB, he ended up being one of the coolest guys I've ever met. He quit his life, he moved to Carmel,
还有他们的生活方式，消除了压力，做了所有这些事情，并最终彻底消除了癌症。其中一个家伙曾经是一名消防员，他得了肺癌，千真万确。最后他成了，JB，他成了我见过的最酷的家伙之一。他辞去了生活，搬到了卡梅尔（Carmel），
and he became a caddy at Pebble. And he's one of, yeah, this guy Ryan, and he's one of the coolest people I've ever met. And he's like, I just, I wake up every morning and I walk, my wife does it, we make all this stuff, and I've changed my life, and I like being a caddy, I'm out here in the thing, he plays golf as well. He's like, and I've just.
并在圆石滩（Pebble）当了一名球童。他就是其中一个，是的，这个叫瑞安的家伙，他是我见过的最酷的人之一。他说，我只是，我每天醒来就去散步，我妻子也一样，我们制作所有这些东西，我改变了生活，我喜欢当球童，我在外面这个地方，他也打高尔夫球。他说，我只是。
Zero stress. This is what I do now. Zero stress, he refused the chemo and he beat it. Now, again, I don't know if it works for, but he really did it and he went full bore, he leaned into it. And in addition to beating the cancer, and I think he was predisposed to be this way,
零压力。这就是我现在的生活。零压力，他拒绝了化疗并战胜了癌症。现在，再说一次，我不知道这是否对所有人管用，但他真的做到了，他全身心地投入其中。除了战胜癌症，而且我认为他本来就有这种倾向，
he had an incredible energy about him. He was an incredibly empathetic, kind person. And he had an aura about him. Like really pretty amazing. That's cool. Or you can wake up every morning and eat a Pop-Tart and stress out about your bottom line, right, Sean? And answer emails like a gopher.
他身上有一种不可思议的能量。他是一个极其富有同理心、善良的人。他身上有一种气场。真的非常了不起。这挺酷的。或者你可以每天早晨醒来吃一个果酱馅饼（Pop-Tart），然后为你的底线压力山大，对吧，肖恩？像个地鼠一样回复电子邮件。
That's me, Parker, by the way. Before you hit send, you get a reply from a shop. Dee pop tarts. I'm not angry. Dee pop tarts shot. I do sometimes, I have a couple boxes in there now. With a glass of milk. With a glass of milk, but I have to cut down on the sugar
顺便说一句，那是我，帕克。在你点击发送之前，你会收到商店的回信。得了吧果酱馅饼。我没有生气。得了吧果酱馅饼商店。我有时会这样，我现在那里还有几盒。配一杯牛奶。配一杯牛奶，但我必须减少糖分
just because it's not, I don't have to cut it all the way out, I just have to cut it down a little bit. How'd it go last night? I didn't have a dessert last night for the first time in like 10 years. And did you wake up feeling a little snappier? I did actually, I slept a little better actually. Yeah, that's what happens.
只是因为它不是，我不必完全戒掉，我只需要稍微减少一点。昨晚进展得怎么样？昨晚我10年来第一次没有吃甜食。你醒来时有没有觉得精神好了一点？确实有，事实上我觉确实睡得好一点了。对，事情就是这样。
Now Parker, when you were in Thailand, did you see a lot of the Ayurvedic folks and some of your yoga practice? I bet was, there was a lot of- Oh my God, I did it all, I was so excited. I bet that was a dream for you, you must have loved it there. It was a dream. I heard about this place I was so excited. I bet that was a dream for you, you must have loved it there.
现在帕克，当你在泰国的时候，你有没有见到很多阿育吠陀的人士，你的一些瑜伽练习？我敢打赌，有很多——天哪，我全都体验了，我太兴奋了。我敢打赌对你来说那就像个梦，你一定很喜欢那里。那是个梦。我听说这个地方，我太兴奋了。我敢打赌对你来说那就像个梦，你一定很喜欢那里。
It was a dream. I heard about this place called Kamaliah. Mike's lawyer's wife, I just struck up a conversation, we had all just landed there like a week, you know? And she said, I'm going to this place called Kamaliah, it's for women of a certain age, and you know, I'm going to go there for two weeks
那是个梦。我听说过一个叫卡玛莉亚（Kamaliah）的地方。迈克律师的妻子，我只是和她搭话，我们所有人都刚落地大概一个星期，你知道吗？她说，我要去一个叫卡玛莉亚的地方，那是为特定年龄的女性准备的，你知道的，我要去那里呆两周，
and get this all sorted out. And then I saw her two weeks later and she was just like, oh really? What do you mean, just exhausted? No. Transform. She was like it changed my life.
把这一切都理顺。然后两周后我见到她时，她就像是，哦，真的吗？你什么意思，只是筋疲力尽吗？不是。脱胎换骨。她觉得这改变了她的生活。
Yeah, wow. She got grounded, she was centered, she was like, it opened up a lot of healing. And so this place and these, it's very, there's an Ayurvedic chef there. And it's a wellness center and has one of those plaques that Mike visited this place for White Lotus. You know, a digital detox, please no cell phones at the table
是啊，哇。她变得脚踏实地，内心平静，她觉得，这开启了许多疗愈。所以这个地方和这些，这里非常，那里有一位阿育吠陀厨师。这是一个健康中心，上面有一块牌匾，上面写着迈克为了《白莲花度假村》参观了这个地方。你知道的，数字排毒，餐桌上请勿使用手机
and all of that. And there was a communal table. I mean, I got to stay there for six weeks. Oh my God. Wow. And I did Reiki, I did sound baths, I went to that liminal space you were talking about earlier in the show. Right, the hip-hop.
诸如此类的。那里有一张公共餐桌。我的意思是，我在那里呆了六周。天哪。哇。我做了灵气疗法（Reiki），做了颂钵音疗（sound baths），我去了你刚才在节目中提到的那个阈限空间。对，嘻盘。
Where you're in between consciousness and you're in a theta state, I think it's called, too. And I had waking moments and dreams and I saw things and it was like, it was founded on a monk's cave, like 25 years ago. This couple, John and Karina, met each other and then reconnected and built this beautiful place. So it's, the thing about Thailand that is so special
就是你处于意识之间，处于西塔波（theta state）状态，我想它也被这么叫。我有过清醒的时刻和梦境，我看到了各种东西，就像是，它建立在一个僧侣的洞穴之上，大约25年前。这对夫妇，约翰和卡琳娜，相遇了，然后重新联系并建造了这个美丽的地方。所以，关于泰国最特别的一点
are the people. Yeah. Like, a rite of passage as a, you know, I don't know how old, as a 13-year-old, maybe in high school, is to live in a monastery and live off the kindness of others who are going to drop off food for you to eat. Wow, wow. So they have, it's a lot of reciprocity.
是这里的人们。对。就像，作为一个，你知道的，我不知道多大年纪，作为一个13岁的孩子，也许在高中时，人生的一个成人礼就是在寺庙里生活，靠那些为你送食物来吃的人们的善意度日。哇，哇。所以他们有，这是一种很多的互惠。
Okay, at Kamaliah, there was a doctor named Dr. Cern. I had this muumuu kaftan dress on with dogs on it. And so she knew I loved dogs. I had this Moo Moo caftan dress on with dogs on it. And so she knew I loved dogs. And so she told me about her, she showed me pictures of her dog KK. KK means crooked and tie. And KK had crooked eyes and his little like, you know, a mix, kind of a corgi mix, but a little stockier.
好吧，在卡玛莉亚，有一位医生叫瑟恩医生（Dr. Cern）。我当时穿着一件印有狗狗图案的宽松长袍（muumuu kaftan）。所以她知道我喜欢狗。我穿着一件印有狗狗图案的宽松长袍。所以她知道我喜欢狗。于是她跟我讲了她的，她给我看了她的狗狗KK的照片。KK在泰语里是“歪”的意思。KK的眼睛有点斜，它是一只小混血，有点像柯基犬的混血，但更壮实一点。
And the dog, she showed me these pictures of KK with like carrying a dead leaf, like a leaf or a branch in his mouth, her mouth. Even KK knows to bring offerings when she wants something. So she would make offerings of like a leaf or something, she'd bring it to the door for food at the back door, Isn't that the best? And then when you got back to the United States,
那只狗，她给我看了这些照片，KK嘴里叼着一片死叶子，一片叶子或是一根树枝。甚至连KK都知道在想要什么的时候带上供品。所以它会制作像一片叶子之类的供品，把它带到后门的食物门口，这不是最棒的吗？然后当你回到美国的时候，
you're like, this is the best country in the world. So listen. Hey, Van Nuys. Woo! No, wait. They're so kind. Like it's so, they're so present with you. And it's just so, yeah, anyway.
你会觉得，这是世界上最好的国家。所以听着。嘿，范奈斯。呜！不，等等。他们太友善了。就像是，他们对你非常专注。而且非常，对，总之。
I can tell you guys kind of spaced out and checked out. No, we were listening. No, I love that. We were listening. We were listening, I love that. Parker. No, Dazin confused. Party Girl, you were queen of the indies.
我看得出你们两个有点走神和状况外了。不，我们在听。不，我喜欢这样。我们在听。我们在听，我喜欢这样。帕克。不，达辛（Dazin）很困惑。派对女孩，你可是独立电影女王。
All the Waiting for Guffin, Best in Show, White Lotus, you killed in that show. You have, remind me the name of the movie that's coming out. It's called the waiting for guff and best in show, White Lotus, you killed in that show. You have, remind me the name of the movie that's coming out. It's called Wild Horse Nine. Yes, and really quick, before, do you remember when I came to your apartment in New York when you were practicing mandolin for Mighty Wind?
所有的《等待古夫曼》、《爱犬v观》、《白莲花度假村》，你在里面演得太棒了。你，提醒我一下那部即将上映的电影叫什么名字。叫《等待古夫曼》、《爱犬v观》、《白莲花度假村》，你在里面演得太棒了。你，提醒我一下那部即将上映的电影叫什么名字。叫《野马九号》。是的，还有，快说，在你之前，你还记得我什么时候去你在纽约的公寓，当时你正在为《最后的风笛手》（A Mighty Wind）练习曼陀林吗？
Yes, that's right! Yes, and I sat there in your apartment with you and you're like, I want to see what it's like to be in a Christopher Guest movie. And you showed me the outline of Best in Show, or no, of A Mighty Wind. And I was like, oh really, so you just make all this stuff up, like you completely improvise, it's really cool.
对，没错！是的，我坐在你的公寓里陪着你，你说，我想看看参演克里斯托弗·盖斯特（Christopher Guest）的电影是什么感觉。你向我展示了《爱犬v观》的大纲，或者说，是《最后的风笛手》的大纲。当时我就想，哦，真的吗？所以你们把这些东西全都是现编的，完全是即兴发挥，真的太酷了。
And then you were showing me the song that you were making up with the mandolin. I just thought that was fascinating to me. And what a fun. I think I kind of got what it was to learn an instrument at the end there. Like I could start jamming with songs and then get that kind of space. Yeah, that was so cool.
然后你向我展示了你用曼陀林创作的歌曲。我当时觉得这对我来说太迷人了。这真是一次有趣的经历。我觉得我最后好像终于懂得了学习一门乐器是怎么回事。就像我可以跟着歌曲即兴演奏，然后进入那种状态。对，太酷了。
I'm so glad I got to do that. Do you remember our Oscar-winning film we did together called The Sweetest Thing? Yes! I mean, was that not, you just creatively, the most fulfilling. Yeah, I know, we just killed it. Right?
我很高兴我能经历这一切。你还记得我们一起拍的那部获得奥斯卡奖的电影《甜姐辣情》（The Sweetest Thing）吗？记得！我的意思是，那难道不是，你在创意上最满足的一次。对，我懂，我们简直绝了。对吧？
We killed it. I love that. I was so excited to be working with you. We all, will you stay? I really enjoyed hanging out with you guys. You know, you do these things, and then you don't really feel like you're hanging out. And so this is a lot of fun.
我们演得太棒了。我太喜欢了。能和你合作我太兴奋了。我们都，你会留下来吗？我真的很享受和你们一起闲逛。你知道的，你做了这些事情，然后你其实并不觉得是在闲逛。所以这真的很有趣。
Well, we're going to come over to the chateau right now. We're going to have lunch. Yeah, we're going to speed over. I have something at 2.30, and that's it. Parker, we love you very much. Love you guys. Thank you for being here. Such a fan.
好吧，我们现在就要去城堡那边了。我们要去吃午饭。对，我们要快点赶过去。我2点30分有个安排，就这样。帕克，我们非常爱你。爱你们。谢谢你们来到这里。我是你们的超级粉丝。
Such a massive fan. I hope you win for White Lotus because you deserve it. Yes, please. Thank you. I just hope I'm nominated. Yes, I hope that. I'm honored to be nominated and I hope that happens. So thank you for sending out that Hollywood vibe.
超级大粉丝。我希望你能凭《白莲花度假村》获奖，因为你实至名归。是的，求你了。谢谢。我只希望我能被提名。对，我希望如此。我很荣幸能被提名，我希望那能发生。所以谢谢你们散发出的这种好莱坞氛围。
I love it. You get our votes. Thank you guys. Bye, honey. Love you. Thank you, Parker out that Hollywood vibe. I love it. You get our votes. Thank you guys. Bye, honey, love you. Thank you, Parker. Love you guys, thank you. Bye, bye, bye. Oh, then she just covers up.
我喜欢。你得到了我们的选票。谢谢你们，伙计们。再见，亲爱的。爱你们。谢谢你，帕克散发出的这种好莱坞氛围。我喜欢。你得到了我们的选票。谢谢你们，伙计们。再见，亲爱的，爱你们。谢谢你，帕克。爱你们，谢谢。拜拜。哦，然后她直接挂断了。
Look at that. Look at that. She knows what she's doing. I know what I'm doing. Love her. Wow, yeah, really. That Parker. She's so funny.
看那个。看那个。她知道自己在做什么。我知道我在做什么。爱她。哇，对，真的。那个帕克。她太有趣了。
She's an original. Yeah. Oh, it's just consistently exciting so funny. She's an original. Yeah. Oh, it's just consistently exciting to watch. She was on Will and Grace a lot, many episodes of Will and Grace. Oh really? Why didn't we talk about that? Yeah, what happened to that?
她是个独一无二的人。对啊。哦，看着她总是这么让人兴奋，太有趣了。她演过好多集《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）。哦，真的吗？我们怎么没聊到这个？对啊，那怎么回事？
I didn't know whether to be like, hey, remember when you were on Will and Grace? Yeah, I didn't have any question about it. It didn't stop me. Yeah, about what? Did it stop you? Remember when we did Sweetest Thing together? Yeah, I know.
我当时不知道该不该说，嘿，还记得你演过《威尔和格蕾丝》吗？对，我对这个没有任何疑问。这并没有阻止我。对，关于什么？这阻止你了吗？还记得我们一起拍《甜姐辣情》的时候吗？对，我知道。
But yeah, I mean, she's always been so kind. I've never met her before. I remember. Oh really? Isn't she hilarious? Yeah, she's amazing. She's great. She's as advertised.
但对啊，我的意思是，她一直都那么友善。我以前从未见过她。我记得。哦，真的吗？她不是很搞笑吗？对，她太棒了。她好极了。她名不虚传。
She delivers. Yeah, and she's, I don't know, but you guys, I love all that kind of talk about like all that healing stuff and that Iveristic or whatever it's called. That's what it was, Ivoristic, good for you. Or something, Ivoristic. Ayurvedic.
她说到做到。对啊，而且她，我不知道，不过你们俩，我喜欢所有那种关于疗愈的事情，还有那个叫什么“伊伏里斯特”还是什么的。就是那个，伊伏里斯特，真有你的。或者别的什么，伊伏里斯特。阿育吠陀。
Ayurvedic, that's what it is. Ayurvedic, I want to learn more about that. No you don't. We want you to learn more about it. I do, actually. I actually do want to learn more about it. Why don't you go to Thailand for six weeks and go to that fucking wellness center
阿育吠陀，就是那个。阿育吠陀，我想了解更多。不，你不想。我们想让你多了解一点。我真的想。我其实真的想了解更多。你怎么不去泰国呆上六周，去那个该死的健康中心
and get yourself flushed out. Yeah, why don't you go fucking, you won't even go to the 405. What do you think, he's going to fucking Thailand? Scrape some of the impacted bowels you've got right out. Can you imagine if he had to go to a place that he didn't have access to, Jeopardy every night? He'd be fucking them up.
把自己里外冲洗干净。对，你怎么不去该死的，你连405高速公路都不肯上。你觉得他会去该死的泰国吗？把你肠子里那些宿便全刮出来。你能想象如果他不得不去一个他无法每晚看《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）的地方吗？他会气疯的。
Or Wheel of Fortune. Wheel of Fortune, never fucking happening. No, I'm not going to Thailand. No. I appreciate these almonds, but do you have any hickory almonds? Yes, absolutely. How about when she stopped for that butterfly?
或者《幸运轮》（Wheel of Fortune）。《幸运轮》，绝对不可能发生。不，我才不去泰国。不。我很感激这些杏仁，不过你们有山核桃杏仁吗？有的，当然。她为那只蝴蝶停下来的时候怎么样？
I love that. And, you know, a butterfly rhymes with... Here they come. Here it comes. Butter... Bye? What? No.
我太喜欢了。而且，你知道的，蝴蝶（butterfly）押韵于……他们来了。它来了。巴特……拜（Butter... bye）？什么？不。
That's not even a thing, man. I know, it rhymes with butterfly. No. Keep working. You can just make sure. Will and I will talk for a while and you do some Google searching, come up with a bye. Will, what's going on with your mic stand? I don't know, man.
这根本说不通，老兄。我知道，它和“butterfly”押韵。不对。继续干。你可以确保一下。我和威尔聊一会儿，你用谷歌搜索一下，想出一个“bye”。威尔，你的麦克风支架怎么了？不知道，老兄。
Leave it alone. Is there anyone in the office with you, Will? Yeah, there are 300 people here. Yeah, oh yeah. What are they doing? Counting paper clips? They're working, man. They're working away.
别管它。办公室里有人和你在一起吗，威尔？对，这里有300人。对，哦，对。他们在干什么？数回形针吗？他们在工作，老兄。他们正在努力工作。
We got Twisted Metal Season Two coming out this summer on Peacock. Oh, look at that. Give it a plug. Twisted Metal. Well, you asked. You asked. This is a behind the scenes tour, hard rock tour. Super Team Canada, we got Super Team Canada coming out.
我们的《烈火战车》（Twisted Metal）第二季今年夏天将在Peacock上播出。哦，看那个。宣传一下。《烈火战车》。好吧，你问的。你问的。这是一次幕后巡演，硬摇滚巡演。超级加拿大队，我们的《超级加拿大队》（Super Team Canada）要上映了。
That's already out. That's an animated show. Check it out. It's fantastic. We also have our new doc that just got released, Sexiest Man in Winnipeg. Listen, we got a lot of things going on, okay? Sure, sure, sure, sure, yeah.
那个已经上映了。那是一部动画片。去看看吧。棒极了。我们还有刚发布的新纪录片《温尼伯最性感男人》。听着，我们有很多事情要忙，好吧？当然，当然，当然，当然，对。
So Sexiest Man in Winnipeg, that's about a doctor? Have you said, he just got out of prison? Do you want to know the truth is, it's about a guy who was a sports supporter. Anytime you're ready, Sean. I can't find one. Fuck. You can't come up with a buy?
所以《温尼伯最性感男人》，那是关于一个医生的吗？你说过，他刚出狱？你想知道真相吗，这是一个关于一个体育记者开始抢劫银行的故事。千真万确。好吧，听起来有很多故事在进行。听起来你是在把这个故事和另一个故事
I had a whole list. Oh. It's The Sexiest Man in Winnipeg. And it's about a guy who's a sports reporter who started robbing banks. True story. Well, it sounds like a lot of stories going on. It sounds like you're taking one and another one
然后你组合……咬它们！咬它们！咬咬咬咬咬它们！不要放任不管，只是为了让痛苦消失。聪明。少。聪明。
and you're coming... Biting them! Biting them! B-b-b-b-biting them! Don't allow it just to make the pain go away. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。SmartLess由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔姆杰夫（Rob Armjarf）和贝内特·巴尔贝科（Bennett Barbeco）100%有机手工制作。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbeco. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少一点。SmartLess 是由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjarf 和 Bennett Barbeco 100% 有机手工制作的。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。